madame monsieur bonsoir au moins 27
morts et des dizaines de blessés une
tempête sans précédent a frappé le nord
de la france ce soir de nombreux
départements sont toujours paralysés
sans électricité sans transport le
mauvais temps a endommagé nos liaisons
techniques et nous n'avons pas pu
recevoir l'ensemble des images tournées
par nos stations régionales dans ce
journal nous allons tout de même tenté
de faire un état des lieux
commençons par l'ile-de-france où les
dégâts sont impressionnants
olivier sainte marie le bilan aurait pu
être encore plus sûrs en quelques
secondes cette grille de plusieurs tall
s'est effondré sur les hlm l'uqar crée
de la défense et partie des appartements
qui ont été touchés depuis le début de
ce chantier de toute façon on craint
qu'il ya une grue qui nous tombe dessus
on en a parlé à monsieur le maire on en
a parlé à bas la police
on ne pouvait rien faire personne ne
pouvait rien faire et finalement elle
est tombée leur appartement est
complètement bousillé et heureusement il
ya plus gros aucune victime dans cet
immeuble du 16e arrondissement deux
personnes ont été grièvement blessées
par l'effondrement d'une façade sur les
grandes avenues les dégâts sont
importants
moto renversé vitres brisées terrasse
inondées des toits ont été arrachés des
cheminées sont tombés notamment rue de
rivoli
si les champs-elysées ont été
relativement épargnés les roues ont tenu
le coup
les bords de seine en revanche ont été
très touchés d'arriver vers 8 heures
8h15 luther a mis à peu près non il y
avait tellement de vent que j'ai rien
entendu
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de vent au
pied de la tour eiffel le champ de mars
est un champ de bataille
je me sens pas rien je le sens paris en
bretagne sur la côte rue mais sur paris
nous sommes au bord du périphérique la
remorque de son camion n'a pas résisté
aux rafales de vent qui ont parfois
atteint 170 km/heure l'ensemble des
parcs et jardins ont été fermés le
château de versailles est très
endommagée gros dégâts dans le parc on a
perdu
va savoir plus de 4000 arbres c'est le
double datant de la fameuse tempête de
90 qui avait fait tout parler du château
là c'est le double et notamment tous les
vieux arbres depuis 200 ans on voit des
comptes tombaient comme des gros dégâts
et irrémédiable les bâtiments ont
également beaucoup souffert
versailles ne devrait pas ouvrir au
public avant plusieurs jours d'autant
qu'une nouvelle tempête est attendue
la nuit prochaine ce soir le plan orsec
a été déclenché dans quatre départements